[Musique]
outre les effondrements de maisons et
d'immeubles de nombreux glissements de
terrains se produisirent de l'autre côté
de la chaîne montagneuse de kyushu
balafrant les coteaux et provoquant
l'effondrement du grand-pont d'assaut
sur la nationale 3 125 dans la rivière
kurokawa
[Musique]
de mémoire d'homme c'est du jamais vu au
moins d'avril 2016 une série de
tremblements de terre a frappé la zone
de kumamoto avec une secousse principale
de magnitude 7 le 16 avril l'océan
pacifique est ceinturé par un réseau de
failles d'origine tectonique et de
volcans baptisé la ceinture de feu du
pacifique au nord ouest de cette
ceinture honshu et kyushu les îles les
plus peuplées du japon sont à la
jonction de plusieurs plaques la plaque
océanique des philippines
ils rentrent en collision avec plusieurs
plaques eurasienne et créer une faille
médiane qui circule sous les îles du sud
ouest à l'est à l'extrémité sud de cette
zone de rupture la préfecture de
kumamoto est construite sur un mille
feuilles de roche
chaque année plusieurs dizaines de
secousses telluriques qui sont
ressenties
l'épicentre du séisme se situe à
quelques 100 km au sud est de sendai sur
l'île de honshu à l'endroit où un
tremblement de terre et un tsunami ont
tout dévasté en mars 2011
ces six matchs ou chou ne se situait pas
sur la plaque de la zone de subduction
mais sur une zone sur laquelle il ya de
nombreuses failles actives qui court sur
tout le centre de kyushu les routes
furent terriblement endommagé entre le
14 et le 20 avril ce sont plus de 600
répliques sismiques qui ont été
ressenties dont deux particulièrement
forte
quinze mille soldats de l'armée
japonaise prirent part aux opérations de
secours dans les jours qui suivirent le
tremblement de terre
la recherche et le sauvetage
c'est l'une de nos priorités majeures le
17 avril
le premier ministre japonais shinzo abe
mobilisent à 3000 soldats de l'armée de
l'air pour permettre aux autorités
locales d'atteindre les zones sinistrées
[Musique]
je fais partie des équipes de recherche
et de sauvetage
à l'heure actuelle nous recherchons des
personnes qui ont disparu
c'est la première fois que je vois un
tremblement de terre et un glissement de
terrain d'une telle ampleur depuis que
je suis arrivé ici nous avons déjà
trouvé de quatre personnes
une personne de plus reste introuvable
donc nous allons chercher toute la nuit
c'était une occurrence naturel et
personne n'a rien vu venir
nous n'avons aucun indice
on ne sait pas où les maisons ont été
emportées
en faisant des recherches basées sur des
suppositions sans pour autant
le temps presse pour retrouver des
survivants l'équipe se prépare à passer
une nuit blanche